Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a South Korean comedy film called
“Timer.” Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
In the near future, a device is developed
which allows one to see the exact time they
will meet their soulmate. It is called the next
revolutionary step in digital matchmaking by
many. A facility called the “Timer” offers such
service to common people. They insert a chip on
your wrist that counts down to the day you meet
your soulmate. When two soulmates come in close
proximity, the timer goes off, letting them know
that they have met each other. However, the timer
won’t start until both the people have gotten
the chip embedded in their wrists. Oona is a Los
Angeles orthodontist who has an unblinking timer,
meaning that her soulmate isn’t equipped with one.
She has come to the Timer office with her
recent boyfriend to find out if he is really
the one. The worker named Matchmaker Patty is
good friends with Oona because she is one of their
frequent customers. Oona has brought several guys
to the facility in hopes of finding her soulmate.
Her boyfriend is clearly nervous before going
in because if their timer doesn’t match,
they will have to break up.
Patty makes him sign a document and embeds his
wrist with the implant. It starts to blink almost
immediately showing him that he has two years left
to meet his soulmate. Oona looks at her timer
hoping for it to start blinking but it never
does. Her boyfriend is glad that he will meet his
soulmate right when he finishes medical school.
After finding out they are not the one for each
other, they break up and go their separate ways.
Oona's stepsister and roommate, Steph, has a timer
that says she will not meet her soulmate for over
15 years. Since she isn’t going to wait for that
long, Steph's lifestyle includes one-night stands
with men who are only looking for a fling like
her. One day, Oona is at a grocery store when
the cashier named Mikey starts a conversation
with her. His compliments flatter Oona but she
notices he already has a timer that has a specific
date on it, meaning that he is not her soulmate.
Mikey also notices her timer but suggests they
can still see each other because soulmates are
in the future anyway. At night, the sisters go
to their parents for dinner but Steph is late
as always. She notices Oona is sad about her
ex-boyfriend and advises her to resort to
one night stands until she meets the one.
At their parent’s house, everyone is excited
for their younger brother Jesse to get his
timer embedded for the first time. They have
even invited a matchmaker to celebrate the event
together. The matchmaker plants the implant and it
immediately shows Jess only has three days left
to meet his soulmate. Everyone is happy for him
but Oona thinks it’s unfair. She congratulates
her little brother and leaves without waiting
for dinner. She drives back to the grocery store
to meet Mikey. At first, she hesitates to go in
but does it anyway. Mikey is left stunned when
she asks him out. He quickly asks his co-worker
to take his place and follows her back to the
car. The car ride to Mikey’s home is awkward
as the two don’t have anything in common to talk
about. They finally reach Mikey’s apartment and
are greeted by four of his roommates. The house
is trashed with beer bottles and tissue papers
which makes Oona rethink her decision.
She also tells Mikey that she is turning
thirty soon and regrets it instantly.
When she is about to leave, Mikey persuades her
to stay and the two finally kiss. But she notices
his timer again which only has four months left
in it. Oona realizes what she is doing is wrong
and leaves after apologizing. The following day,
she is surprised by Mikey coming to her job as
a patient. He assumes that she doesn’t like him
because he is a cashier and explains that he
does music as well. He tries to persuade her,
claiming that the timer only shows you a definite
path and life is about detours. But Oona bluntly
states that he is not the one for her so she is
not wasting time on him. Moreover, she feels like
he is cheating on his future soulmate. At night,
she goes on a blind date with a man but is clearly
very bored. He only talks when she asks him
questions, so the date ends on a bad note. To get
over it, Oona goes to a club and meets Mikey yet
again. He is a drummer in the band performing at
the club. The two make eye contact and end up in
Mikey’s room at the end of the day. As they make
out, his roommates arrive at the house and disturb
them. Mikey asks all of them to shut up because
this is the only chance he will get with someone
like Oona who is way out of his league.
Meanwhile, Steph is at her job as a receptionist
at a nursing home when a handsome man
named Dan walks in. She is interested in him but
is disappointed to notice he doesn’t have a timer.
At home, she asks Oona about her night and is
proud of her for finally getting with a guy.
She also advises her to never meet him again
because she might get hurt. It is finally the
day Oona’s brother gets to meet his soulmate. His
parents excitedly send him to school but the whole
day passes without his timer ringing. When he
finally returns home, their house maid introduces
him to her daughter Soledad and the timer finally
goes off. While Jesse's mother is excited,
Soledad’s parents rudely leave the premises with
her. In the evening, Oona is about to return home
from work when Mikey startles her. She hits him in
the face but quickly composes herself, and the two
drive back to her house. Oona kisses him after
making sure Steph isn’t around. Starting then,
they start to date. Oona goes to his house
frequently and makes friends with his roommates.
She tells him about her biological father
who is a music producer. She hasn’t talked
to him since he and his mother broke up.
One day at work, Steph gets yelled at by her boss
for not receiving calls. Dan lies to him and gets
her out of the situation. He is clearly interested
in Steph but she seems to not care. Still, she
asks him out, planning to set up a date between
him and Oona. She tells Oona to be at the club in
the evening because she hasn’t been out lately.
Oona feels bad for not telling Steph about Mikey
but she is afraid of being judged. Later that day,
Steph and Dan wait for Oona at the bar for a long
time but she doesn’t come. Instead, she hangs out
with Mikey in her room. Steph and Dan talk for
a long time. Dan tells her about his wife who
died three years ago. He believes that she was his
soulmate so he never had to plant the timer on his
wrist. As the conversation continues, they start
to like each other. But when Steph returns home,
she is furious at Oona for abandoning her. She
sees Mikey in her room and figures out they have
been seeing each other in secret. Things get
heated when the sisters begin to argue about
Mikey’s timer. He interrupts them and reveals that
his timer is actually a sticker that he bought so
he would feel included. He doesn’t actually
believe in timers and would never get one.
Oona is in utter shock and mad at him for lying
to her all along. She furiously asks him to leave.
Their time together had only been enjoyable
because she thought it wouldn’t last long,
now that she knows he doesn’t have a timer, she
feels betrayed. For the next week, she doesn’t
try to contact him but is miserable at the same
time. She finally decides to talk to him and
tells him that she is sorry. They meet at Oona’s
parents’ house for thanksgiving. Their house maid
and her daughter have also gathered for the
meal. Mikey knows how to speak in Spanish so he
gets along with them easily. Oona answers all the
questions that her parents ask Mikey and doesn’t
let him speak. It is evident that she is ashamed
of being in a relationship with someone so young
and naive. Meanwhile, Dan and Steph meet
a couple of times and start dating. Oona,
on the other hand, is now unsure how she feels
about Mikey. Moreover, her mother urges her to
find out if Mikey is her soulmate as soon
as possible. One day, he suddenly confesses
that he loves her but Oona panics and leaves.
She and Steph then go to see Oona’s biological
father Rick. They are received by a young
woman who happens to be Rick’s girlfriend.
The first few minutes are awkward because Oona
hasn’t talked to him for a long time. Then,
she bluntly asks him why he never got a timer. The
man shows her the timer on his wrist and tells her
he has one but he still has some time left to meet
his soulmate. Then, his girlfriend tells them she
had her timer removed because she loves Rick and
doesn’t care what the timer says. The sisters
are inspired by her, so they rush to get theirs
removed, promising to live their life without
depending on a stupid countdown. Matchmaker Kaite
is in utter shock to find out the girls want to
remove their timers. She and the manager warn them
that if the device is removed once, they cannot
replant it again so this will be their last chance
of finding true love. Steph says she doesn’t care
and finally removes hers. But when it is Oona’s
turn, she hesitates. Seconds before it is removed,
the timer starts to beep. It turns out that her
soulmate got his timer embedded right then.
Oona only has five hours to meet him. She decides
to leave it on for that time out of curiosity but
Steph gets mad at her. The following day is their
shared birthday. At night, Oona’s countdown stops,
meaning she will meet her soulmate the next
day. Their mother organizes a birthday party
for the two of them. She has invited Dan and Mikey
both. Steph arrives at the house first and hangs
out with Dan. Mikey, on the other hand, is busy
translating a conversation between the housemaid
and Oona’s mother. They decide to stay as boss and
worker and let their kids take their relationship
further themselves. When Oona arrives at the
party, her timer rings along with Dan’s, meaning
that he is her soulmate. An annoyed Steph storms
off to the kitchen while Mikey leaves for his
house. Dan follows Steph behind and asks her if
she is okay. Oona joins the two to talk about the
situation. Steph starts to yell at Oona for always
getting everything she wants in life. She believes
that Oona has taken away Dan, who is the only
person she was ever interested in. The sisters get
into a fight which ends when Oona tells Steph she
is her best friend and she doesn’t want Dan.
After Oona leaves, Dan tells Steph that he got a
timer because it was important for her and that
he doesn’t care for her sister. The following
morning, Oona goes to meet Mikey at his house.
She shows him that she got her timer
removed because she wants to be with him.
Mikey is confused at first but then finally kisses
her. The next day, Steph wakes Oona up and they
solve their differences. In the last scene,
Oona then goes out on a run and coincidentally
meets Dan. They talk for a while and find
out they have a lot in common. But at last,
they laugh and go their separate ways.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.